chaque année ce sont plus de 200
incendies qui se déclarent dans les
fermes du Québec seulement toute
production confondue ça équivaut à
quatre bâtiments agricoles qui sont la
proie des flammes chaque semaine les
pertes matériels sont évidemment
colossales mais dans 37% des cas c'est
bâtiments abritent des animaux le plus
souvent ce sont des bovins laitiers le
drame est alors encore plus grand
[Musique]
les animaux à l'entrée à l'automne au
mode de novembre 2020 il y avait de la
place pour 300 pattes là dans les tables
que le bâtiment
ici à l'âge de 2 mois puis il était
classé en parc selon l'âge puis tourner
juste à l'autre bout puis revenir de ce
côté-ci jusqu'à là où je vais là
[Musique]
les vaches puis j'ai vu le nuage de
fumée de chez moi c'est un voisin qui
m'a appelé me dire que le foot est pris
ici
[Musique]
dans l'après-midi du 15 août 2022 à
saint docteur
incendie détruit tout le bâtiment de la
ferme de Patrick et de son frère Dany
Croteau un bâtiment
l'incendie
évolue très rapidement dans un incendie
de grange puis c'est dans les trois
quatre premières minutes où il y a
possibilité de sortir des bêtes au-delà
on est plus capable de rentrer seulement
l'émotion est forte chez les éleveurs
c'est ce qui nous demande c'est de
sortir leur bête mais ça dépend toujours
où on arrive durant l'intervention
quand mon frère arrivé avant moi lui
avait pas de il voyait pas de flamme
encore puis quand il s'est mis à voir
les flammes le plafond descendu
on a la série sortir des animaux pour
simplement
le bâtiment était occupé par les futurs
vaches laitières des génisses de moins
de 24 mois
235 bêtes presque toutes mortes
ont pu en évacuer une vingtaine il en
reste une quinzaine vivante
c'est sûr que notre premier objectif
c'est de terminer l'agonie puis la
souffrance de toutes les animaux qui
évidemment ne pourront pas passer au
travers
l'incendie d'une étable entraîne presque
à tout coup la mort du troupeau pourquoi
l'instinct de l'animal et la composition
de certains matériaux
d'abord par le redera très développé les
bovins détectent la fumée rapidement et
donne la larme sont capables de détecter
un peu au niveau de l'urine au niveau
des fesses que les autres animaux aussi
sont en danger
en revanche ne cherche pas à se sauver
d'alerte les bovins se disent mot
grégaire donc le premier réflexe de se
regrouper ensemble puis de pouvoir avoir
un esprit de groupe pour pouvoir se
protéger de l'environnement le bâtiment
c'est leur place de confort ils sont en
sécurité ils veulent rester en groupe
pour se protéger elle résiste
pour les pompiers toutes les fois qu'on
a vécu d'essayer de sortir les vaches
c'est difficile puis c'est le même son
de cloche quand on discute avec les
autres services incendies aux alentours
pire elle revienne dans les tables pour
mourir justement il y en a une qui est
assortie puis qu'on a vu rentrer qu'on
n'a jamais été capable de récupérer si
on réussit à les sortir mais souvent ils
veulent retourner en intérieur du
bâtiment pour retrouver leur congénères
parce qu'à l'extérieur c'est pas un
endroit où est-ce qu'ils sont habitués
ou est-ce qu'ils sont en confiance parce
que souvent c'est la première fois qu'il
voit cet environnement là
devant lesquels les pompiers sont
impuissants le chef Patrick Morin l'a
déjà vécu en sortant des vaches on a les
œufs de rentrer puis à ce moment-là
on
attaque l'incendie
comme dans presque toutes les fermes les
étables ne sont pas reliées à l'Aqueduc
municipale il n'y a pas de bornes
fontaines sur place l'eau est
transportée par camion-citerne et le
débit du puit artésien est trop faible
pour un système de gicleur d'eau
[Musique]
la quinzaine de génisses que les
crottons ont réussi à sauver portent des
marques de brûlures différentes en
surface et en profondeur d'une bête à
l'autre
on peut un peu comme on le fait en
médecine humaine parler des différentes
profondeurs des degrés premiers degré 2e
3e degré qui réfère à la profondeur et
plus la profondeur de la brûlure est
importante moi il y a de chances que ça
soit remplacer par de la peau mais ça va
être remplacé par du tissu cicatriciel
de la fibrose puis un moment donné ça va
être une énorme cicatrice si la surface
est grande la peau c'est un élément très
très important pour nous protéger de
l'environnement il y a plein de microbes
qui pourraient vouloir nous envahir
quand la peau n'est plus intacte s'il y
a des grandes surfaces puis en plus que
la brûlure est profonde on peut tout de
suite penser que même si au moment de
l'examen ça l'animal nous apparaît
relativement confortable les défis
devant nous vont être énormes en plus
des blessures externes les risques de
blessures internes sont élevées
un élément important aussi pour essayer
d'établir les chances ou le pronostic de
survie d'une vache qui russe à sortir de
bâtiment en incendie c'est justement de
voir le temps que le passé là puis les
chances qu'elle a été pendant de longues
périodes exposées à des gaz toxiques qui
peuvent venir de tous les matériaux qui
recouvrent l'intérieur des bâtiments
ces matériaux dangereux se trouvent dans
les bâtiments récents il recouvre le
plafond et les murs de contreplaqué les
plastiques le PVC ou le vinyle
qui est de plastique puis de couleur
blanche qui permet de refléter bien la
lumière puis de plus étant exttemps
plastiques mais on peut le nettoyer
facilement puis au niveau de l'hygiène
du bâtiment en général c'est beaucoup
plus facile un matériau de choix mais un
danger en cas d'incendie
sous l'effet de chaleur intense ces
matières plastiques fondent et dégage
entre autres de l'acide chlorhydrique
aux vapeur corrosifs
qui peut nous faire penser que l'animal
en ne respiré une grande quantité c'est
la brûlure justement puis l'état de la
face puis du faciès de l'animal et on
peut présumer là tout de suite on peut
s'imaginer que les gaz toxiques
qu'elles respirent vont descendre dans
la trachée ces gaz là sont non seulement
toxiques parce que leur propre nature
leur composition mais sont aussi très
très chaud puis d'ailleurs
l'auscultation va être franchement
anormal parce que rappelez-vous
contrairement aux équins beaucoup moins
de cages thoraciques chez les vaches les
vapeurs de plastique fondu peuvent
détériorer le système respiratoire de
façon permanente les substances toxiques
une fois inhalées vont causer des
dommages importants aux petites cellules
qui recouvrent les alvéoles et le
premier réflexe une fois que c'est
cellules là sont détruites de façon
massive ça sorte qu'on est capable de
reconnaître avec le stéthoscope le
système pulmonaire endommagé risque
d’être marqué de séquelles on peut
penser que c'est assez sérieux une
partie de ceux soit faite par du
succatriciel de la fibrose pulmonaire
donc sa capacité globale va être
clairement moins que ce que l'été de ce
qu'elle était auparavant ça c'est sûr
le Code national de construction des
bâtiments agricoles n'oblige pas la pose
d'avertisseurs de fumée dans les étables
qui d'ailleurs serait inadapté dans
l'humidité et la poussière
user de techniques adéquates pourraient
sauver des vies
si on a pu prévoir des allées assez
larges des sorties des portes de sortie
à ce large pour qu'ils puissent sortir
de par deux ou en groupe ça va encore
mieux les bambins ont une vision très
particulière puis juste la route ou le
chemin qui vont emprunter faudrait qu'au
niveau de la vision au niveau du sol que
les couleurs ou les textures soient
uniformes tout au long du passage comme
on voit là la différence entre du béton
puis un tapis de caoutchouc on a un
changement de texture changement de
couleur quand les animaux arrivent à
cette hauteur là mais un freinage puis
ça demande je dois tout traverser ou pas
on peut appliquer de la Rupt du brentis
de la litière juste pour garder la
texture uniforme la couleur uniforme
pour éviter le freinage soudain des
animaux lors du déplacement de sorte que
l'éleveur puisse agir contre l'instinct
de ces animaux et de mourir à
l'intérieur
de comprendre un peu l'animal que ça
peut nous donner peut-être des minutes
de plus
si on est capable de manipuler les
animaux de façon un petit peu plus
rapide ben ça donne une chance de
pouvoir les sauver
ah c'est toujours les animaux qui sont
toujours ça on travaille on travaille
pour élever une vache qui va être
rentable qui va être parfaite pour nous
puis tout l'élevage est parti
les croûtons ont perdu la relève de
leurs troupeau de 325 vaches malgré tout
ils ont racheté des animaux et décider
de reconstruire les tables on peut pas
juste mettre la clé dans la porte puis
dire que on va recommencer dans 15 jours
là c'est
et quand le feu a pris dans l'après-midi
on était au champ à trois heures mon
frère il est parti il est allé en scellé
aussi que les employés parce qu'on
n'avait pas le choix là c'est
comme ça
notre routine à continuer à continuer
pareil
[Musique]